the shooting in uvalde texas yesterday
was the deadliest attack at a u.s grade
school since the sandy hook massacre in
connecticut nearly 10 years ago now
that's when a gunman killed 20 little
children and six adults
noble marquez green lost her
six-year-old daughter anna grace that
day in the sandy hook shooting
marquez green is a licensed marriage and
family therapist and joins us
unfortunately once again here at the
table to discuss this because i know you
were here last week i knew this would
happen again i didn't think it would be
so soon i'm so glad to see you again
nelba sorry it's these circumstances i
don't know if you got a chance to see
the interview that we had with the
congressman i think a lot of us were
sort of surprised when his reaction was
now is not the time to discuss that
debate that when you weren't trying to
yeah and i wasn't trying to debate him
but he says now is not the time to have
to debate about gun reform laws
what do you think when you hear that i
was enraged i felt like he completely
gaslet you and the questions you asked
he talked about faith and love as if
there was
uh faith you know we have these extremes
faith and love or action action is faith
action
is love you mean to tell me you didn't
learn after newtown that this could
happen in the community
please do not gaslit my faith and my
love because when we love people we keep
them
safe and we are not keeping people safe
yeah i was thinking about you yesterday
i saw interviews with several new town
parents who said this is very triggering
they feel like they're living this all
over again when you heard the new how
did you hear the news and do you feel
like you're reliving it all over again
as well
i received a text on my phone that said
please don't look at the news
and while there is some reliving what my
family and i are committed to is
educating people on how to help these
families and pushing back on these
congress folks who are gaslighting in
every other way
and deciding
to be cowards we don't need more
cowardice now we need courage and we
need much more courage from them
but no but i want people to understand
what these families go through we keep
hearing stories that some of these
parents don't even know yeah if if their
children are victims or not or if
they're in the hospital you know as 10
o'clock last night this morning some of
them still didn't know
what happened on that day
do you know what it's like to be taken
to a room and told and not told
when did you all find out
it was hours later
it was hours later that we were notified
and it was even hours after that that it
was official
and the agony that you face and the
survival
that you have to do in order to get
through something like this we are
asking for superhuman strength from
these parents
now but i have to ask you after newtown
i was there covering it
many people said if not now in terms of
gun reform then when it did not happen
on a national level for the parents who
are out there lobbying so what's your
advice to those who are seeking
you know
background checks and you know to that
degree mental health uh policies that
really have some teeth
where do you go from now where do you go
to now yeah we have to meet their
cowardice
their complacency with
outrage and demanding action we have to
meet them we have to be persistent the
problem with us is
we don't think about this unless there's
a national incident right but the truth
is 120 plus families are impacted by gun
violence every day
if we broadcast that
then maybe it would stay in our minds
but we forget so easily now a couple of
years ago you wrote losing a child to
gun violence is to willingly agree to
inhale tiny shards of glass into your
lungs
families are dealing with this
what is your advice to them in a moment
and i know they probably don't want to
hear it but what would you tell them i
wouldn't advise them i would advise the
people around them who are supporting
them and i would say make a commitment
to being there for those families not
just today not just next week
but 10 and 15 and 20 years from now
because it will still feel like shards
of glass decades later
no but marquez green we appreciate you
we know that this isn't easy but we're
thankful that you're on the show tonight
yes we are